[Aplausos]
[Música]
taiwán se ha convertido en algo así como
la versión asiática de la irreductible
aldea de astérix y obélix un pequeño
enclave rodeado de un gran imperio que
se lo quiere comer y tal y como ocurre
con la pequeña aldea gala los ciudadanos
de taiwán también tienen su particular
pócima mágica para defenderse de sus
enemigos claro que en este caso no se
trata del ungüento preparado por ningún
druida hablamos de los eeuu de la fuerza
de los eeuu bueno de los eeuu y también
recientemente de algo más amigos taiwán
tiene un nuevo aliado un nuevo secreto
que ya está alimentando la ira de pekín
atentos
[Música]
el enfado de pekín
amigos taiwán está haciendo frente a una
enorme presión por parte de la china
continental que tal y como sabéis
reclama la isla como parte de su
territorio y ojo que no estamos hablando
de ningún juego ni del típico tira y
afloja de la política internacional
me la devuelves me la quitas me enfado
te amenazó ahora lo dejamos estar para
nada en este caso pekín ha fijado
incluso fecha de caducidad
veréis el gobierno chino ha dejado claro
una y otra vez que está dispuesto a todo
y que antes del año 2049 el año del
centenario de la república popular china
taiwán deberá reincorporarse a la china
continental
claro que con todo eso hay un problema y
no precisamente pequeño los taiwaneses
no están por la labor no quieren saber
nada de todo esto
[Música]
de hecho os lo hemos contado aquí en
visual político en 2016 el partido
progresista democrático de saint web
una de nuestras premiadas en 2017 por
cierto que se inclina por las tesis
independentistas se hizo con el poder
con todo el poder tanto con el congreso
como con la presidencia y desde entonces
digamos que esto pekín no se lo ha
tomado nada pero que nada bien bueno qué
diantres se lo ha tomado fatal
desde que taiwán se convirtió en
presidenta desde prácticamente el primer
minuto las presiones de pekín contra la
isla se multiplicaron y ya en los
últimos meses están alcanzando niveles
de auténtica obsesión política ha
cortado lazos diplomáticos ha tratado de
castigar económicamente a taiwán y ha
puesto en marcha enormes ejercicios
militares en torno a la isla
pero ahí no queda todo además el
gobierno de xi jinping está utilizando
todos los medios a su alcance para
borrar del mapa el nombre y la identidad
de taiwán
por ejemplo cuando publicamos nuestro
primer vídeo sobre taiwán eran 2020 los
países que reconocían formalmente la
isla como china como la china legítima
sí como ya os contamos taiwán nunca ha
declarado su independencia sino que
durante años se ha reivindicado como el
gobierno legítimo de china y claro
diplomáticamente un país solo puede
tener un gobierno reconocido pues bien
el caso es que pekín ha multiplicado su
agenda diplomática para terminar con
esta situación y hoy apenas un año
después ya son sólo 18 países casi todos
minúsculos pero eso no es todo de hecho
dadas las circunstancias este movimiento
de pekín sería comprensible algo así
como yo soy el gobierno legítimo de
china pero lo cierto es que esto ya no
es una cuestión sobre quiénes son o al
gobierno legítimo sino que simplemente
pekín ha dicho por activa y por pasiva
que nunca va a permitir la independencia
de taiwán y una forma de impedirlo es
precisamente tratando de borrar todo
rastro de la identidad nación
de la isla en el mundo taiwán qué es eso
de taiwán una marca de coches
fijaos en esta línea pekín está
bloqueando la presencia de los
representantes de taiwán e incluso de
sus periodistas en todos los órganos
internacionales que pueden como por
ejemplo la organización mundial de la
salud está montando a las empresas que
venden productos en china con la
etiqueta made in taiwan le ha pasado por
ejemplo a la cadena japonesa muy otro
caso que conocemos es el de la cadena de
ropa gap que ha tenido que disculparse
por vender en norteamérica camisetas que
no incluyen a taiwán como parte de china
luego grupos de música taiwaneses como
la banda de indie punk fight ex que no
son partidarios de la reunificación
están desapareciendo de los servicios
chinos de música en 'streaming' y
queréis un último ejemplo pues ante la
amenaza de pekín las compañías aéreas de
todo el mundo están dejando de utilizar
el nombre de la isla si tal cual como lo
escucháis ni siquiera las compañías
estadounidenses utilizan ya el nombre de
taiwán es decir si podéis reservar un
billete a taipei desde nueva york pero
simplemente no preguntéis a qué país
vais eso sí a diferencia de otras
compañías internacionales como british
airways o lufthansa que ya sitúan a la
hora de vender los billetes a taiwán
como parte
las compañías estadounidenses han
recurrido simplemente al truco del país
fantasma vendiendo billetes a taipei
pero que donde está eso a quién le
importa claro que no podemos culpar las
el mercado de la aviación chino es
demasiado grande y además muchas
compañías tienen intereses directos en
el país la meta de china respecto a
taiwán nunca ha cambiado su objetivo es
acabar con la soberanía de taiwán
exterminar la democracia taiwanesa y
lograr la unificación definitiva lee
teng-hui primer presidente elegido
democráticamente de taiwán sin embargo
espera un momento porque no todos son
malas noticias para taiwán junto al
apoyo de los eeuu a la isla de ha
surgido otro poderoso aliado o mejor
dicho
taiwán está desarrollando su propia
pócima mágica y no no estoy hablando de
armas atentos
la meca de la libertad
amigos taiwán ha sido elegida como el
primer anfitrión asiático del foro de la
libertad de oslo algo así como un
congreso un encuentro internacional
sobre derechos humanos pero claro puede
que alguno de vosotros esté preguntando
un congreso el seso realmente tan
importante pues lo cierto amigos es que
si no tanto por el propio congreso sino
sobre todo por lo que significa
aunque la democracia mundial ha
experimentado una tendencia general de
retroceso en los últimos años la
democracia de taiwán ha persistido y
sigue prosperando taiwán puede continuar
sirviendo de inspiración a los
demócratas de asia incluidos los de
china que teach en vicepresidente de la
fundación para la democracia de taiwán
veréis durante décadas hong kong fue el
gran bastión de la libertad de expresión
en esta zona del mundo
tanto los medios de comunicación
internacionales como las organizaciones
de derechos humanos se establecieron
allí sus sedes y no sólo eso hong kong
también se convirtió en todo un refugio
para muchos exiliados políticos como por
ejemplo los líderes estudiantiles que
lideraron las protestas de tiananmen t
sin embargo en los últimos tiempos y
como ya hemos visto aquí en visual
político las cosas están cambiando y
pekín ha endurecido su control sobre la
política hongkonesa
[Música]
hong kong fue originalmente la primera
opción para la oficina de asia pero hoy
china no solo reprime a su propio pueblo
ahora está exportando cada vez más esa
represión a hong kong
wu'er kaixi disidente chino y miembros
de reporteros sin fronteras pero al
mismo tiempo que se producía este cambio
taiwán se ha consolidado como una
democracia vibrante y uno de los lugares
más libres de toda la región
precisamente por eso está sustituyendo a
hong kong como la meca para los
activistas por la libertad y los
derechos humanos en toda asia y eso que
hasta 1987 taiwán estuvo bajo el control
de una férrea dictadura
[Música]
ahora por ejemplo uno de los festivales
de cine sobre derechos humanos que se
celebraban en hong kong se ha trasladado
a taiwán land wing y uno de los editores
de libros de hong kong que fue
secuestrado por agentes del gobierno
chino hace dos años ha anunciado que
reabrirá su librería en taiwán y
reporteros sin fronteras anunció en 2017
que su primera oficina asiática estará
en taipei la libertad de expresión es
muy importante en la cultura taiwanesa
cedric alviani director de la oficina de
reporteros sin fronteras en taipei
amigos estos son sólo algunos ejemplos
de lo que ya es una tendencia
generalizada democracia pluralidad
política libertad de expresión derechos
humanos matrimonio sexual
da igual se está convirtiendo en toda
una referencia y evidentemente esto
plantea un problema enorme para los
intereses chinos por un lado los
taiwaneses están encantados con la
libertad así que por supuesto no quieren
saber absolutamente nada de volver a
estar bajo las órdenes de pekín por otro
lado mientras el gobierno chino trata de
borrar de aniquilar la identidad de
taiwán en el mundo el país emerge de
repente como un centro de libertad
a la influencia que ello conlleva
además claro es mucho más difícil
plantearse agredir a un país que es
conocido precisamente por su apuesta por
los derechos humanos la comunidad
internacional no podría aceptarlo o al
menos no tendría mucho más difícil y
amigos precisamente esta puede ser la
mejor jugada de taiwán atentos
la nueva jugada
[Aplausos]
a mediados del pasado mes de julio de
2018 entró en servicio el segundo
escuadrón de helicópteros apache made in
taiwan forma parte de lo que está siendo
un fortalecimiento en la alianza entre
washington y taipei de lo que por cierto
hablaremos en un próximo vídeo que entre
otras cosas contempla un importante
incremento en la venta de equipos y
tecnología militar a la isla
taiwán está comprando helicópteros
tanques misiles sistemas antiaéreos y
ahora incluso quiere desarrollar sus
propios submarinos sin embargo a pesar
de todo ello cada vez parece más claro
que tan solo militarmente taiwán va a
tener muy difícil frenar a china la
diferencia de presupuestos es bestial el
gasto militar de china es entre 15 y 20
veces el de taiwán y eso a la larga se
nota
si es verdad hoy por hoy está el
paraguas de los eeuu pero incluso con
eso no basta para tener la garantía de
que la comunidad internacional actuaría
en su favor
taiwán necesita reforzar su influencia
en el mundo sobre todo si aspira a
convertirse a todas luces en un país
independiente ahora bien la pregunta que
podemos hacernos es cómo diantres
lograrlo
[Música]
pues amigos aunque nos pueda sorprender
la estrategia militar siendo
imprescindible tal vez no sea la más
importante taiwán tiene sobre todo que
ganar influencia y protagonismo en el
mundo al tiempo que logra superar los
problemas económicos de los que ya os
hablamos en un anterior vídeo para ello
puede por ejemplo buscar atraer a
estudiantes de toda asia y de todo el
mundo dándoles facilidades impulsando
los programas en inglés y atrayendo
profesores del primer nivel
eso supondría ganar mucha influencia y
claro capital humano también 2º taiwán
puede poner en marcha una política
agresiva para atraer multinacionales y
lograr que establezcan aquí no sólo sus
fábricas sino sobre todo centros de
investigación y sedes administrativas
ojo dedicándole especial atención a la
atracción de empresas de creación de
contenidos medios de comunicación
estudios de cines
youtubers porque no etcétera etcétera
pero el gobierno podría buscar
convertirse en todo un enclave logístico
por ejemplo desarrollando sus
capacidades aeroportuarias y
convirtiéndose así en un gran hub de
comunicaciones cuarto puede atraer más
profesionales del resto de asia lo que
le permitiría por un lado enfrentarse al
envejecimiento de la población de la
isla y por otro reforzar sus lazos con
los lugares de origen de estos
trabajadores y quinto tiene que
continuar impulsando su papel como
centro de los derechos humanos y la
libertad de expresión
tal vez un plan de estas características
no sea tan excitante como enormes planes
de armas pero resultaría mucho más
económico tratar de competir con china
solo con la vía militar se antoja
complicado impulsaría la economía de la
isla y le daría muchísima influencia en
todo el mundo dadas las circunstancias
una universidad un estudio de cine un
hotel o la sede de una organización de
derechos humanos o una multinacional
pueden ser mucho más importantes para la
supervivencia de la isla que por ejemplo
un barco de guerra y no no se trata de
tener un discurso ultra pacifista ni
nada por el estilo se trata de puro
pragmatismo por eso cada vez son más los
que se inclinan en la isla por este tipo
de estrategias pero amigos para terminar
me vais a permitir hacer una reflexión
veréis los países democráticos tal vez
cometieron un grave error cuando
permitieron que hong kong terminará no
sólo volviendo a formar parte de china
sino sobre todo que volviera a estar
bajo el control político de pekín
los que nos veis habitualmente sabéis
que en visual político le otorgamos un
gran protagonismo a china y que no solo
no somos pesimistas sino que reconocemos
muchas contribuciones positivas que
están teniendo su origen en el gigante
asiático ahí está por ejemplo el
despegue de áfrica sin embargo amigos el
papel de china con taiwán es muy pero
que muy diferente y me pregunto
realmente queremos repetir el mismo
error que con hong kong pero ahora turno
para ti crees que la comunidad
internacional debe garantizar la
seguridad de taiwán déjanos tu respuesta
en los comentarios y también en esta
encuesta si te ha resultado interesante
el vídeo dale a like y no olvides
suscribirte a visual político un saludo
y hasta la próxima
[Música]